the IMAX experience is all about getting
you into the movie making you part of
that movie and Hollywood filmmakers are
looking for something that
differentiates their film we have
cameras that have been up in space we've
got cameras that have gone to the bottom
of the ocean we've got cameras that run
at high speeds we've got them all the
goal of the digital camera was to build
something that was smaller more compact
lightweight something that's easy to use
on location what's unique about our 3d
digital camera is that we use a fully
integrated camera system where the
lenses are interchangeable we're not
using a beam splitter rig which makes
our camera very compact but our lenses
literally come off as a stereo pair
whereas in a conventional beam splitter
rig there are separate right eye and
left eye lenses which would need to be
realigned every time a lens change is
made transformers is an action movie
there's a lots of fast action sequences
and cars in locations that are dusty and
dirty and they found this camera to be
invaluable we were able to do some
really crazy action scenes that we would
never be able to get with a larger
camera so chase vehicles aerial mounts
places where things are moving quick
that's a really big advantage to having
a smaller camera one of the biggest
problems for anyone trying to capture
sea animal behavior is you sit there
watching for ages and ages for the
animal to do something interesting and
the instant it does you have to try and
get your mixture your cameras turned on
and if you're just a little too late you
missed that the new IMAX digital camera
has this special record mode where it's
continuously running when you hit the Go
button to actually start capturing
footage you've already got backwards in
time a minute to two minutes so it's a
really great way to save extraordinary
things that happen spontaneously while
you're shooting the whole pedigree
behind IMAX it's about always having the
best possible image and as we move into
the digital world that's going to
continue to be our goal to be one step
ahead and have the best image quality
through the entire chain even for
non-technical audience members
they're always blown away by what they
see the clarity the resolution the the
detail they're truly spectacular quality
of images
you